oh boy where were you when all the Vegas
news broke and what was your reaction
when you first heard it actually I woke
up in the yesterday morning I had a text
from Gayle who said massacre in Vegas
turn on the TV because sometimes I'm
late turning on the TV and so that's
where I first hit and I have to tell you
I feel the same way the whole country
feels I feel like my soul is aching for
the soul of the country your show would
address a lot of stuff like this where
people were in pain what would you say
to people now to deal with something
like this well you know there's not a
day that goes by that I'm not putting on
my shoes or brushing my teeth where I
just think of the ordinariness of people
who went to a concert or the
ordinariness of the day from people from
9/11 who was just doing an ordinary
thing and then you'd never get home so I
would say that these moments of crisis
and tragedy are to remind us all to be
present in the ordinariness of our lives
that actually turns out to be
extraordinary when the person you love
doesn't come home that night you are in
the moment when you're at all right I
pay attention to things you know this is
to make us all more awakened about our
own life you know and the fact that it
shows up this way is a horror but as I
heard someone say seeing people coming
together helping each other whether it's
this crisis that we're in or whether
what we saw weeks ago in in in Houston
and in Florida and now in Puerto Rico
it shows the humanity of us all so it's
an opportunity for us to show the best
of ourselves when the worst shows up you
know you have such a way - of bringing
people together and a lot of this and
light at the tragedy is gonna scare a
lot of people of going out and doing
such a public thing and going to big
crowds and what would you say to those
people who now are scared just to live
their life we can't allow ourselves to
be frightened into not living our lives
and
I think that we have to keep going and
we have to keep going with the faith
that things will get better and things
will get better when we make them better
[Music]
you